hey
wanna play hide and grab
oh the horror genre what a decade it's
been am i right the rumblings of a
quality horror comeback felt during the
2000s morphed into a full-blown
renaissance during the 2010s the 2010
started with a bumper crop of unlikely
remake success stories meanwhile movies
like cabin in the woods were hilariously
tearing apart the foundations of horror
tropes creaky after decades of abuse
allowing for something else to be built
upon the remains no matter what happens
we have to stay together
this isn't right
what what's the matter
this isn't right we should split up
while 2013's the conjuring turned
relentless old-school scares into
blockbuster business 2014 marks the
beginning of a new nightmare that really
took shape with an unexpected headline
grabber like the babadook all in all
this was going to be horror in the 2010s
an unseen force spreading into
bewildering frontiers of intimate grief
and personal storytelling frequently on
back to basics budgets and by 2017
horror was all but inescapable in the
record books at the oscars on streaming
services and of course at your local
theater
[Laughter]
oh
no
no
no
no no no no no no no no no no no
so we took all these movies and more and
ranked them by adjusted tomato meter
which factors in release year and number
of reviews to help compare movies of
different sizes and times speaking of
because the competition is so cutthroat
we put in a 40 review minimum ensuring
the most critically buzzed were the ones
to fill out the collection alright we've
delayed the inevitable long enough so
whether you're here to find new horror
movies and recommendations or to let the
last 10 years of diabolical memories
come rushing back see the blood sweat
tears and more blood that made this
decade one to carry to the grave an art
countdown of the best horror movies of
the 2010s
[Music]
starting with number 10 under the shadow
after she day's building is hit by a
missile during the iran iraq war a
superstitious neighbor suggests that the
missile was cursed and might be carrying
malevolent middle eastern spirits she
becomes convinced a supernatural force
within the building is attempting to
possess her daughter dorsa and she has
no choice but to confront these forces
if she is to save her daughter and
herself starring nargis rashidi avin
manchadi bobby nadiri and directed by
bebek anvari critics say under the
shadow deftly blends seemingly disparate
genres to deliver an effective chiller
with timely themes and thought-provoking
social subtexts
foreign
number nine it
seven young outcasts in derry maine are
about to face their worst nightmare an
ancient shape-shifting evil that emerges
from the sewer every 27 years to prey on
the town's children banding together
over the course of one horrifying summer
the friends must overcome their own
personal fears to battle the murderous
bloodthirsty clown known as pennywise
starring jaden martell sophia lillis
bill skarsgard and directed by andy
muschetti critics say well-acted and
fiendishly frightening with an
emotionally affecting story at its core
it amplifies the horror and stephen
king's classic story without losing
touch with its heart
georgie
what a nice boat
do you want it back
um yes please you look like a nice boy i
bet you have a lot of friends
three but my brother's my best ass where
is he
in bed
sick
i bet i could cheer him up i'll give him
a balloon
do you want a balloon too georgie
i'm not supposed to take stuff from
strangers oh
well i'm pennywise
dancing clown
pennywise
yes me georgie
georgie
meet pennywise
now we aren't strangers
are we
number eight the cabin in the woods
when five college friends arrive at a
remote forest cavern for a little
vacation little do they expect the
horrors that await them one by one they
all fall victim to backwoods zombies but
there is another factor at play two
scientists are manipulating the ghoulish
goings-on but even as the body count
rises there is yet more at work than
meets the eye starring kristin connolly
chris hemsworth frane crans and directed
by drew goddard critics say the cabin in
the woods is an astonishing metaphy
capable of being funny strange and scary
frequently all at the same time
god
uh
number seven the witch
in 1630 new england panic and despair
envelops a farmer his wife and their
children when youngest son samuel
suddenly vanishes the family blames
thomason the oldest daughter who was
watching the boy at the time of his
disappearance with suspicion and
paranoia mounting twin siblings mercy
and jonas suspect thomason of witchcraft
testing the clan's faith loyalty and
love to one another starring anya taylor
joy ralph ennison kate dickey and
directed by robert eggers critics say as
thought-provoking as it is visually
compelling the witch delivers a deeply
unsettling exercise in slow building
horror that suggests great things for
debuting writer director robert eggers
hey
[Music]
[Music]
sam
number six it follows
after carefree teenager jay sleeps with
her new boyfriend hugh for the first
time she learns that she is the latest
recipient of a fatal curse that is
passed from victim to victim via sexual
intercourse death jay learns will creep
inexorably toward her as either a friend
or a stranger jay's friends don't
believe her seemingly paranoid ravings
until they too begin to see the phantom
assassins and band together to help her
flee or defend herself starring micah
monroe kier gilchrist daniel zavado and
directed by david robert mitchell
critics say smart original and above all
terrifying it follows is a rare modern
horror film that works on multiple
levels and leaves a lingering sting
there's something wrong with me
look somebody broke the window
that really happened
i saw a girl in the kitchen
okay
love you
you're okay
you don't believe me
mom
mom is at you no it's me
yara yeah
don't open the door
see
everything's okay
what are you doing
number five hereditary
when the matriarch of the graham family
passes away her daughter and
grandchildren begin to unravel cryptic
and increasingly terrifying secrets
about their ancestry trying to outrun
the sinister fate that they have
inherited starring tony collette millie
shapiro alex wolff and directed by ari
astor critics say hereditary uses its
classic setup as a framework for a
harrowing uncommonly unsettling horror
film whose cold touch lingers long
beyond the closing credits
why are you scared of me
what
i never wanted to be your mother
why
i was scared
i didn't feel like a mother
but she pressured me
then why did you have me it wasn't my
fault i tried to stop it
how
i tried to have a miscarriage
however i could i did everything they
told me not to do but it didn't work
i'm happy it didn't work
you tried to kill me
[Music]
[Applause]
number four the babadook
a troubled widow discovers that her son
is telling the truth about a monster
that entered their home through the
pages of a children's book starring
essie davis noah weissman barbara west
and directed by jennifer kent critics
say the babadook relies on real horror
rather than cheap jump scares and boasts
a heartfelt genuinely moving story to
boot
[Music]
hey
oh
number three a quiet place
if they hear you they hunt you a family
must live in silence to avoid mysterious
creatures that hunt by sound knowing
that even the slightest whisper or
footstep can bring death evelyn and lee
are determined to find a way to protect
their children while desperately
searching for a way to fight back
starring emily blunt millicent simmons
and john krasinski who also directed the
movie critics say a quiet place artfully
plays on elemental fears with a
ruthlessly intelligent creature feature
that's as original as it is scary and
establishes director john krasinski as a
rising talent
uh
number two get out
now that chris and his girlfriend rose
have reached the meet the parents
milestone of dating she invites him for
a weekend getaway with missy and dean at
first chris reads the family's overly
accommodating behavior as nervous
attempts to deal with their daughter's
interracial relationship but as the
weekend progresses a series of
increasingly disturbing discoveries
leads him to a truth that he could never
have imagined starring daniel kaluuya
alison williams bradley whitford and
directed by jordan peele critics say
funny scary and thought-provoking get
out seamlessly weaves its tretchent
social critiques into a brilliantly
effective and entertaining horror comedy
thrill ride do you find the vin african
america as more advantage or
disadvantage
in the modern world
it's a tough one
yeah
i don't know man
hey
yo man
they were asking me about the
african-american experience maybe you
could take this one
oh
well well
i find that the african-american
experience for me has been for the most
part very good
although
i find it difficult to go into detail as
i haven't had much desire to leave the
house in a while
we've become such homebodies yes yes yes
but even when you go into the city i've
just had no interest
the chores have become my sanctuary
get out
sorry man okay
get out
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
tigers are not afraid
when a girl's mother disappears leaving
her on her own she joins a gang of
street children leading to a tragic
chain of events starring paula lara juan
ramon lopez hansel casillas and directed
by isa lopez critics say tigers are not
afraid draws on childhood trauma for a
story that definitely blends magical
fantasy and hard-hitting realism and
leaves a lingering impact
foreign
[Music]
ready or not
grace couldn't be happier after she
marries the man of her dreams at his
family's luxurious estate there's just
one catch she must now hide from
midnight until dawn while her new
in-laws hunt her down with guns
crossbows and other weapons as grace
desperately tries to survive the night
she soon finds a way to turn the tables
on her not-so-lovable relatives starring
samara weaving adam brody mark o'brien
and directed by matt vettinelli open and
tyler gillette critics say smart
subversive and darkly funny ready or not
is a crowd-pleasing horror film with
giddily entertaining bite whenever the
ludomasas are presented with
a new addition to the family
we place a blank playing card into the
box
our initiate
then
has the privilege of drawing the card
and mr labelle
will tell us which game to play
i got chess i got old maid seriously
what the [ __ ] is old maid fitch
[Music]
so i just
take out the card
my dear
it is your turn
[Music]
[Laughter]
what does it say girl
says hide and seek are we really gonna
play that
everything okay
and before we get to number one here is
another honorable mention
the conjuring
in 1970 paranormal investigators and
demonologists lorraine and ed warren are
summoned to the home of carolyn and
roger perrin the parents and their five
daughters have recently moved into a
secluded farmhouse where a supernatural
presence has made itself known though
the manifestations are relatively benign
at first events soon escalate in
horrifying fashion especially after the
warrens discover the house's macabre
history starring vera farmiga patrick
wilson lily taylor and directed by james
wan critics say well crafted and
gleefully creepy the conjuring ratchets
up dread through a series of effective
old school scares are you all right
do you see it
see what
there's someone behind the door
what
there's someone standing over there
i i don't see anyone
it's looking right at us
no look
look
there's no one there's no one here
see
ugh does that smell again
oh
my god
it's standing right behind you
[Music]
and finally number one us
accompanied by her husband son and
daughter adelaide wilson returns to the
beachfront home where she grew up as a
child haunted by a traumatic experience
from the past adelaide grows
increasingly concerned that something
bad is going to happen her worst fears
soon become a reality when four masked
strangers descend upon the house forcing
the wilsons into a fight for survival
when the masks come off the family is
horrified to learn that each attacker
takes the appearance of one of them
starring lupita nyong'o winston duke
elizabeth moss and directed by jordan
peele critics say with jordan peel's
second inventive ambitious horror film
we have seen how to beat the sophomore
jinx and it is us
foreign
so
oh
[Music]
well friends that about does it for us
be sure to stay tuned to the rotten
tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content that you love and
for even more news scores and
recommendations on the latest tv shows
and movies go to rottentomatoes.com
until next time i'm your host naz perez
and we'll see you back here for more top
10s on the rotten tomatoes countdown
[Music]
you